last night we showed you a pretty
shocking video actually from within
Stanford law school and it showed
someone who identified as a quote
diversity Dean lecturing a sitting
federal judge who's a serious person on
the quote harms that he caused and that
video got us thinking about the state of
colleges and universities in this
country why are there so many diversity
Deans and why are they like this
tabia Lee is a former diversity director
at De Anza College she was removed from
her role for questioning the school's
anti-racist policies and she joins us
now mostly thank you so much for coming
on
um so that tell us your story if you
would because it's it's a little
shocking honestly but I think it tells
us a lot about the state of higher
education
well thank you Tucker I was hired on at
De Anza College in 2021 as a faculty
director of an office of equity social
justice and Multicultural education and
this was my lifelong dream of a tenure
track faculty leadership position and I
thought that I would be afforded you
know the academic freedom and freedom of
expression that's available to any
faculty member and what I discovered was
that as I started to you know enact my
teaching approach which I was very
transparent about when I was hired on
what I seek to do is bring together
people of diverse and Divergent
perspectives and to identify points of
commonality between those so that we can
best serve our students as I began to do
that work there was a severe backlash
from some of the extremists on the
campus who identify themselves as woke
and as aligned with critical social
justice ideology and they attacked me
viciously they subverted my tenure
review process to do so and it saddens
me as someone who benefited from
California community colleges as you
know foundational to my scholarship and
to who I am today to see the state that
we're in and to see the tenure review
process misused and abused by
individuals for reasons of not wanting
to have multiple perspectives and
Viewpoint diversity and critical
thinking which is part of the mission of
California community colleges I I can't
think of anything more virtuous than
bringing people with different beliefs
together to find something that they
have in common I mean it's what the
country really needs of course but I
have the feeling that the Divergent
viewpoints part of your mission was the
offensive part
yes unfortunately
um you know as I did my needs assessment
conversations multiple people did tell
me that there was some issues with
Viewpoint diversity and you know certain
groups uh small groups but vocal groups
of people
um being really reticent to engage with
a divergent or diverse perspectives and
as I began to do my work these
individuals were Seated on my tenure
Review Committee and they began to
attack my work for doing exactly that
you know I I'm someone who I talk about
teacher ideology and practice and what
I'm really trying to do through that
work is get teachers to become more
conscious about the ideologies that they
express embody and enact in their
teaching
and that is something that I do I don't
work from a singular ideal ideological
perspective or even promote you know any
particular ideological perspective what
I'm doing is bringing adult Learners
diverse opinions in viewpoints and also
letting them know there's many ways to
do this work not just one and for not
Towing the line of absolute Fidelity to
a critical social justice ideology I Was
Made of pariah my work was undermined my
leadership was undermined by Key Senior
leaders and faculty members there and
they literally obstructed me from from
doing my work and I was subjected to
censorship and profanity in the tenure
review process and it was just something
that was really hard to see because you
know as Educators there's a certain
level of professionalism and civil
discourse that we should engage everyone
with whether they're different from us
or not
I hope you sue them into the Stone Age
and I it's so nice of you to come out
and tell your story tonight which is a
scary story but we appreciate Leslie
thank you very much
thank you Tucker I appreciate your time
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight